a jackpot winning in a dotty's casino
gone terribly wrong and now an employee
of the establishment is dead
six-year-old alicia gibolina described a
strong-willed and kind-hearted by loved
ones madison kimbrough on this story she
spoke to those closest to her along with
a witness who was there during her final
moments madison joins us live near
flamingo and jones with their story
i spoke to several people very close to
alicia including a witness who was here
at the dotties you're looking at right
now at the time of the incident who says
the whole ordeal has left so many
searching for answers
i saw alicia the manager pursuing after
him
and
she went around
the driver's side door that was open and
was
what looked like trying to
recover the purse sixty-year-old alicia
gibolino was trying to do the right
thing wednesday when a thief took off
with a customer's purse at dottie's
casino that's when alicia stepped in
tragically losing her life in the
process i told dispatch that she wasn't
breathing
and she was bleeding from her nose and
they asked me if i
could roll her over
and
start cpr chest compressions alicia's
friends and family devastated a woman
who followed the rules and did what was
right that's how her husband miguel of
22 years describes her while miguel did
not want to be interviewed on camera her
best friend kathleen hull shared with me
their bond and how influential alicia
was in her life she was someone you
could just always depend on
no matter when i was upset with my kids
or my boyfriend she was that person that
you call my heart just goes out for
miguel
miguel is just one of those simple guys
he just was really good and
he loved alicia so much
you know that was his whole world the
man police are looking for was said to
be in a stolen suv it is a black 2021
mercedes gl5 with nevada plates 56 5t
77. the thought that he could do this to
one person he could do this to somebody
else and another family could be going
through this tomorrow
and there is a gofundme page set up for
alicia we have that link up on our
website reporting near flamingo and
jones madison kimbrough live local now